[Music]
to one hey everyone what's up welcome to
simulation I'm Alan Saucon we are
sitting down with dekai dr. du chí
thanks are you out of the show I'm
fantastic a to be here really appreciate
it and as you guys know we like to make
very helped make very complex subjects
really relatable for people and inspire
you to build the future so today we're
gonna be talking about language we're
going to be talking about cognitive
science and we're gonna unpack this in a
lot of detail it's gonna be fun
alright wants to do this so you haven't
you know Hugh have a long background in
this field from all the way from
University of California San Diego then
to Kellogg and the Hong Kong University
of Science and Technology and then to
Berkeley yeah well Berkeley actually
came long before the MBA from Kellogg
image a definite bit so was the opposite
yeah okay cool
and so then like on this path where
where exactly were you like I know that
I like language I like computer science
how did you figure that out you know I I
really I really don't know it sir so I
grew up in these are circumstances in
the middle of the country I was born st.
Louis heavily grew up in Chicago and you
know I was I was apparently picking out
melodies on pianos when I was two I
don't remember this
I suppose life and you know sort of like
musically embroiled since I was speaking
but then I was also you know sort of
challenged with this multilingual
environment because you know coming from
a family where my parents had emigrated
as teenagers to the US we had multiple
languages floating around
and this is in Middle America right and
so I'm seeing radically different
cultures and languages and music you
know like I was I was getting trained
classically you know in the School of
Music at at Northwestern University but
at the same time Chicago is like the
home of the Blues yeah you know much of
American music and and my my blues and
jazz teachers are busily subverting
everything they were teaching in the
classical conservatory style so you know
it was just a mishmash and so by the
time I got to you know back to San Diego
in high school and dropped out of high
school and then went into UCSD I was
like what am I going to do and I just I
found myself picking because UCSD has
one of these like Oxford Cambridge style
college systems so you don't just go to
UCSD you go to one of the specific
undergrad colleges there and each one
has a different philosophy right and and
the college I picked which is Ravel
College was the Renaissance ideal
liberal arts kind of College where for
the first two years you did absolutely
nothing but satisfy these insane
demanding requirements so everybody no
matter what your major was was taking
huge buckets loads of philosophy and
literature and in history in social
sciences as well as the calculus and you
know bio in physics and fine arts
foreign languages and stuff like that
and and so you didn't even get to start
taking your specialization until your
third year basically which sent all the
other engineering students running
screaming away from her Val College into
so less taxing colleges with the
requirements but I was just having a
blast you know it was like sort of okay
this is like everything I love UCSD was
a pioneer in that day and age of
computer music and reminds me was a
Jesuit education system to Renaissance
there's something about that yeah I mean
maybe maybe I've been colored by that
background but but like
to me it feels very weird that we live
in an era where education has been
pigeonholing us into specialties like
sort of like oh you're an engineer or
you know you're a musician so you can't
possibly do blah blah yeah that's kind
of weird grab you and it's an artifact
of the last century or so before that
you either were educated and a thinker
or a creative you know sort of person or
you weren't it wasn't like oh you only
have this very very narrow specialty
you're you're drawing from many
different sources of human knowledge and
and that is where the advances come from
and you know maybe we'll come back to
this topic that I think in this day and
age where we're having again this
dialogue about what AI is doing to the
future of society and employment and
labor I I really think we need to go
back there very quickly
and become whole persons exactly and a
lot of our show is Polymathic yes yeah
very Renaissance jack-of-all-trades or
Jane of all trades in that sense and we
find that to be very important
especially for the future with the
proliferation of exponential
technologies into civilization we'll
need some sort of better path for adults
to help kids get inspired by a diverse
array of subjects as well as going deep
into subjects continuing to do that now
your tongue you're talking about your
background and kind of like where you
figure it out I forgot to mention that
your super musically talented as well
but the combination of music and
language has been fascinating for you as
well as your music actually I think has
meant and your engineering abilities and
your engineering abilities have
augmented your musical abilities and I
think that's you know that's a key from
the Renaissance period as well as people
were both sciency as well as musically
inclined and having that is huge for the
way that you think about yeah I mean
nobody told people like da Vinci oh no
you can't play music because you're an
architect or you're an anatomist or you
know
I mean it's just kind of to me these
things all they're they're all
leveraging each other but you know when
I look at this from a cognitive science
point of view that makes tremendous
amounts of sense right because I mean
look if you look at language you know
you know when I went into AI I was
interested in cognition and and you know
of course AI has many subfields people
talk about vision people talk about
planning and robotics expert systems and
gaming and you know there's all sorts of
different applications of AI why I chose
language is out of all of those
different applications language is
unique in the following sense it's not
only an application of AI to be able to
understand language translate language
whatever language it also the foundation
of intelligence
you know without language we can't think
abstract thoughts beyond things like
ouch or I'm cold or I'm hungry almost
every thought we have is you know an
abstract thought that we're making use
of our linguistic abilities to be able
to think like you know language
structures thought and and so there's
this um you know what I call the grand
cyclist intelligence right that's really
important to make clear it's super
important I mean that's kind of the
slogan from the sapir-whorf hypothesis
that that the languages that you know
strongly determined the the kind of
thoughts that you'll think if the
language has a tendency to be a little
bit more aggressive or a tendency to be
a little bit more kind maybe there is a
bunch of different ways to say the word
love maybe there is an only one way to
save the world word love language is
also what made civilization what it is
today a lot of what it is today is the
language now and let's can we do a
little evolution as well along this
journey go ahead yeah yeah just like
there's there's some really great
examples of this I love so like yeah
when I when I teach this
sometimes I'm teaching in Asia - you
know Chinese speaking audiences and I
ask them ok think about say the campaign
slogan of our previous American
president right you remember what that
was right yes we can no no previous oh
sorry yeah yeah yeah yes we good yeah
and yes we can't right and so how how
would you translate that into a Chinese
campaign slogan hmm and they're like
because you know number one there's no
word for yes in Chinese oh wait is there
word for know also know what well so so
here's the thing right there there's
words for things like true there's words
false there's more abstract words for
like a agree or not agree but and
there's words for things like correct
right but if somebody comes up to you
and says have you yet
you're not gonna say true alright you're
like to say correct or agree you're not
gonna say agree yeah right and so that
kind of what do you say that if in
Chinese you would if it's literally what
you would say is eaten which is eaten I
eat right so I would not over oh right
thing to indicate there's no word for
yes so if we shortened it down like oh
you know have you eaten yet today I
could just literally ask you eaten and
then you'd be like eaten yeah you
probably say eaten or not really yeah
eaten or not and then yeah you're like
not or eaten but you wouldn't say not
you would say mmm not yet not yet or
haven't haven't yet interesting roughly
that's already so interesting right and
so then okay so so there's no word for
yes and then you sorry we can write so
there literally there's a word for we
there's a word for cam right but if you
if you put it that together it would be
sort of as if you you know
somebody came up to you and said we are
able to mmm right they're going okay
yeah right so so and and these are three
of the simplest shortest English words
that kids learn first and yet we can't
even translate that right and and you
know there's similar things in Reverse
one word that Chinese kids learn first
which is almost impossible to translate
into English with the correct
associations you know which is what in
Chinese it's quiet and it wants you know
roughly that the kid is a see I can't
translate it people say good or obedient
but you know that has a kind of a
negative connotation yeah it's sort of a
timid and connotation and it's supposed
to be good and but but in Chinese it's
and its ultimate race ultimate price
it's really really positive right and
and the interesting thing is that there
is actually a good translation into
French right like so in French the word
saj is a fairly good translation set
which is where we get the word sage from
but oh there's been a semantic shift
sorry into English right but like so so
you see how look so strongly language
influences the way we think and
therefore the culture right yeah whether
you even have a word for it or not and
so so language you know very strongly is
the basis for you know how we how we
think how we frame things human
intelligence but time the interesting
thing to me is that music is actually
the foundation of language right so our
ancestors were singing before they were
talking and we were groaning before we
were singing I mean there's only a
handful of species that that actually
can do imitative creative singing so I'm
not talking about like hardwired barks
or something like that mating calls
right we're talking about oh that's an
interesting sound let me imitate it
right and and that's where the
creativity starts coming right and and
those species are actually only a few
species of primates like
bonobos not most primates don't do it
whales and dolphins they do um possibly
earth it's not sure a few species of
births
very few parrots cockatoos Ravens crows
so and the interesting thing about all
of this even you know the even though
these are different families you know
evolutionarily all of those are the most
intelligent representatives of their
family of their families yeah that's not
an accident that's not an accident yeah
that's the only way yep so so the
species that learn to communicate with
one another through an abstraction of
the context of what's around them then
they became kind of the most they
evolved the most they achieved the most
or they were able to progress the most
yeah they're you know exactly but with
with this imitator and creative singing
ability they're able to start using that
for communicative purposes and to evolve
new communication methods and framing
and so over you know the million years
or so of our evolution our linguistic
abilities have strengthened and you know
they were probably scaffolded on earlier
music abilities and then they sort of
continued to co-evolved right and so our
music abilities then took advantage of
the stronger linguistic abilities and so
on and so you have these interesting
grand cycles of intelligence where
language enables us to think more
complex thoughts that let us create more
complex languages that let us create
more complex aweso and meanwhile music
is doing the same thing with language
yeah and you know when you when you
realize that then it becomes very little
surprised that music you know training
especially early music training is is
incredibly well correlated with pretty
much every measure of intelligence that
you can imagine you know whether it's
verbal literacy or remember
or obviously tonal recognition logic
training I do whatever very important
for early childhood development and then
also for the long-term intelligence
absolutely absolutely as well as
multilingual that's if you if you teach
kids a second language a third language
when they're young again super strong
correlations and this is all related and
then you know like when you look at fMRI
studies brain scans and you discover
that music and language are using the
same areas of the brain it all of this
sort of makes sense in the context of
understanding how human intelligence
evolved I really like how mmm how we can
explain it from a perspective of
initially just figuring out how to
vibrate these vocal cords and make some
sort of a gesture towards one another
about safety or danger or hunger or
sleep and these basic lower hierarchy
needs and then it became some sort of a
little book more singing more of the sun
singing in the music and then the words
the association to the this that that
piece of wood actually became wood or
stick and then we were able to then from
there slowly but surely build up this
insane vocabulary that we have now
dictionaries just full of so many words
and then the way that you know I think
we'll would get will get to this but I
really want to talk about the way that
the Pareto distribution applies to
language as well as you know George's if
ands ifs law I find that so fascinating
so maybe maybe now we because we I guess
we laid out the evolution fairly well I
wanted to make sure we did that now as
you start getting into this we talked a
bit about or
childhood development the importance of
music the importance of multilingualism
in the youth and then how that
translates to one's ability to see
things in a new perspective when they're
older so where do we where do we where
do we go from where do we go from there
like as you're studying this what did
you figure out about cognitive science
and how its applied to computer science
and what are the cool takeaways that we
can take from that and build the future
with that so you know here's the thing
the you know I've always been fascinated
by this question from a scientific
standpoint of what human intelligence is
you know it's that's it's one of the
grand mysteries of science right and and
in language and music being pretty much
the only thing that we humans do better
than all other species let me think
about it right we don't we don't see
more sharply we don't climb trees that
well anymore we swim well we don't fly
we don't run faster we're not stronger
what we kind of we're really pretty lame
as a species on the whole we're a little
bit on the electromagnetic spectrum you
know the only thing that saves us is
these unique language and ability and
music capabilities right and so so like
I knew I wanted to work on this and and
the question to me the natural question
to me seemed to be well so how do humans
actually learn this stuff how how did
you learn like how do we learn it yeah
yeah how is it that by the time you turn
four you were able to speak yeah and and
and so this was something that I found
fascinating and and during the times
that I was just doing cognitive science
you know initially at UCSD and then as a
PhD student at Berkeley AI and cognitive
science were really dominated by this
rule based logic based knowledge based
paradigm right and the idea was there
okay we can write down logical inference
rules
that will capture our knowledge whether
it's about syntax or the real world and
things like that and so you know the big
enterprise back then was for people to
be writing these huge knowledge bases
out of logical formalisms and and and my
advisor in my first year there had me
come in and he said look you know I was
fortunate to join a group that was
billing one of the seminal dialogue
systems right and so you know like Siri
and and Alexa and all that kind of stuff
right the this was the group that I was
at was sort of the beginnings of that
sort of dialogue system you could
anybody could walk out it was called the
UNIX consultant right in it and the
people on it where people like Peter
Norvig and legal errands and Jim Martin
Jamie Mayfield and David chin and and
many many other you know people who have
gone on to do wonderful things and and
he and my adviser said look we've got
the suteki parser we've got the semantic
interpreter we've got a goal analyzer so
that you can recognize the plans of the
person who's asking the question and
understand what he's really trying to
get at we've got a planner that will
figure out the solution we've got a user
model to figure out well you know is
this person naive or are they an expert
you know sort of at what level do we
have to speak to them and we've got a
generator that will give you an answer
and we're just missing this tiny little
piece he said we're missing this piece
that because the parser will tell you oh
here's the verb and here's the noun
phrase and you know the direct object
and all that kind of stuff and this
amazing interpreter however it takes as
input a logical symbol a node that you
know for example if the user said how do
I cut the disk space right there well so
you know cuts the verb
you know disk space is the direct object
but like what you the semantic
interpreter needs to know is which node
which symbol in the knowledge
representation are we using for the for
the verb is it cut as in slice cut the
bread is it cut the grass
cut sense of cut you know so meanings
you know shorter shorten is it cut class
which means to skip or is it you know
cut decisis to reduce or is it you know
cut the cheese yeah there's and so I
just need you to to like why don't you
just take this you know it's a month to
write a bridge between the parser and
the semantic interpreter that will
figure out which of those it is whoa
that's a tough job I went away and in
less than a week later I was backing
this up and said there is no way you can
solve this without probability if
there's so many sources of evidence and
it's all matters of you know a degree
right there's no absolute logical rule
about this and there began this six year
battle with my adviser and you know sort
of I was you know back then to argue for
machine learning approaches to argue for
probabilistic approaches and neural net
approaches was certain heretic 'el in
the field you can get published
nobody would you know everything was
about logic right and and handful of us
in the field were fighting this battle
and saying look we can't really solve
the AI problem by modeling the world
trying to write down all the rules of
everything in the world we have to model
the mind how does the mind learn about
the world that's the only way it's ever
gonna scale and and so that was fun and
and you know about two years after that
I thought pass all my you know exams PhD
exams and qualifying at at Berkeley took
off supposedly for a summer travel
around the world you know Silk Road and
Pakistan and India and Tibet and all
over Europe and I was having such a
blast I ran out of money sort of at the
end of the summer I was found myself in
Germany and called up a friend of her
friend said hey I really I've run out of
money I want to keep sustaining the
travel heaven can you find me a
high-paying programming job right and he
said I can but I've just
this cognitive AI group here at the
Technical University in Munich can you
come in an interview with me first and
so I said great and I immediately got
sucked back into research but I had my
freedom because my advisor was like
across the ocean and so I had a whole
year to explore neural networks and
learning approaches probabilistic
approaches and and travel every weekend
and so by the time I got back I was like
firmly set at Berkeley to do this no
matter what it talking about six months
before graduation
one day after yet another chapter draft
had gone to my advisor and it had always
come back covered with red ink and and
and this one day it goes to Kai I
finally understand what you've been
saying all these years this is
incredible this is the best thing ever
and I made a total convert out of him
six months ago
Wow so yeah that was kind of the
beginnings of the whole machine learning
probabilistic approach that that thesis
was actually the first ever application
of something called maximum entropy
modeling and now the language
understanding let's see I want to get
there I what I was thinking about as you
were talking it was all of the diverse
minds that have been working on this for
the last couple of decades and all of
the intense work that has went into it
to actually be able to understand it
well so I was just thinking about every
like these groups of people that had to
work so hard on figuring out what are
the fundamentals of language and and how
it's like you said earlier where that
gap that was missing there's a very
tough thing to figure out if you're
going into maximum entropy yes and the
model of human perception this is this
is interesting
tell us teach us about this
so you know I think the fundamental
problem is that to figure out which
sense of gotcha this is you have to
understand so much of the context you
have to understand who's doing the
cutting what is the thing that's being
cut
what is our contextual situation yeah
right what is your desire you know like
what do I know about what you're when
you really want right and so there's so
many sources of evidence and that that's
the simple case where it's just a single
verb that you're trying to disambiguate
the more complex cases you've got an
entire construct like that an entire
prepositional phrase or relative clause
and you're trying to figure out what is
that attached to so you need some sort
of a formalism that is on the one hand
able to integrate in a in a consistent
way evidence degrees of support for
various hypotheses and on the other hand
you need something which is a formalism
which is able to or is amenable to
machine learning where given training
data you could actually estimate the
parameters and/or the structure of the
model and so you know I was doing this
work in a context where none of the
group around me had any idea about this
stuff so I just found myself deep in the
libraries with you know go poring
through old books about induction
philosophy of induction right and and
you know how you learn and what is
probability theory and how do you
justify inferences and things like that
and and there were little pockets of
people beginning to do outside of
natural language understanding work on
uncertain reasoning and machine learning
using probabilistic approaches but they
were all not tackling the level of
complexity that we have in natural
which right one of the things that you
still find about a lot of machine
learning work is should we show that
example at some point that yeah yeah
absolutely now be a good time or yeah I
think so yeah yeah let's do it
can we yeah let's do it yeah so the so
if you've got a like you know imagine
that you're nai and you're trying to
learn to make sense of what's in the
world and you come across a pattern
right and and there are lots of
different kind of patterns there are but
just to make this point there so that so
that you're looking at this without
being colored by patterns that you're
already familiar with right so you've
got your blank slate you come across a
pattern let's say it looks like this and
now at the same time you hear this
described to you in English week that's
how we as kids learn we learned because
we're seeing patterns in an environment
and mom talks to us right and so you
hear something and you begin to try to
correlate what is the meaning of that
and so let's say that this is what you
hear mom say hmm the question is how on
earth would you figure out what is the
relationship between what mom said and
the pattern mm-hmm
right now if you think about a moment
there's a lot of potential complexity in
here is that how the English relates to
the pattern or is it this
in fact even for this little short seven
word pattern there's already over 5,000
possible relationships and I'm almost
five items yeah and I'm oversimplifying
here because I'm assuming that the
translation between the pattern and the
English is is deterministic that there's
only one possible translation of course
typically that's even worse right
and so this grows exponentially wholly
right it does this and so if you look at
the bottom number there that's like two
trillion you know that's that's like two
point five in Tilian twin Tilian
possible relationships and that's a
short sentence right
many of the sentences that you read
today will be over 200 words long so you
can just imagine how that's going to
explode now compare that to what your
little human child has to do right by
the time they've turned 4 they've
mastered their mother tongue they've
mastered their native language how many
words of training data
have they been exposed to in that entire
lifetime that's right I remember
learning about the importance of having
a lot of training data for young kids to
learn from if the vocabulary if the
breadth of the vocabulary of the parents
is larger that's important for the
child's development and and in fact so
so there's a range but the range is on
the order of 15 million words only it
might be you know 10 million on the
lower end
20 million on the upper end but it's
that order and if you compare that and
that doesn't mean unique words right
this is includes all the repetitions
because we're talking about zip slaw
this includes all the repetitions all
the repetitions that's hanging on that
much it's not even that much yeah it's
only 15 million words yeah and if you
compare that even today to the kinds of
machine learning models that we see
especially deep learning models which
are even more data hungry
I'm needing billions of training
examples trillions of examples right
because they're coping with stuff like
this
and why do they need so much data it's
because the machine learning models are
not really intelligent intelligent
enough yeah they're they're they're
brute force still this is they're like
trying to memorize off of the data
because they're not making the
abstractions the generalizations
intelligently enough yeah from that
small amount of humans can do you right
so the small amount of data and a young
child can make the generalizations about
language versus the machine intelligence
trying to make generalizations with just
15 million words in the language it's
very difficult for them to figure it out
right now and so because of all the
possible relationships between those
words if we're just having a large data
set that they're just looking at to try
and make relationships that's more
difficult than how the human brain
parses the scenario and figures out
there's also other things probably like
the inflection in voice voice as well
you can tell when people are happy or
sad and exactly and their emotional
state of their faces which machines
aren't they're not combining that yet
the words with yeah emotional you know
and and though you know earlier we're
talking about all the different factors
that you need to use when you're trying
to figure out which sense of cut did you
mean and and those are all additional
contextual factors that you know nobody
was thinking about using back then that
today with these more probabilistic or
neural models we can easily handle
they're they're just all part of the
contextual features you've got somebody
says cut it's very different from if
somebody says cut yeah yeah now see you
ended up figuring out how to take all
these different big uses of the same
word and differentiate between them a
machine help a machine differentiate
between them
now how did how does one go about that
you actually have to build feature
recognizers for all these different
kinds of context and then you can put
them into a maximum entropy bottle or
you can put them into you know other
kinds of neural network models or
probabilistic models the interesting
thing is that when you have to do this
over an entire sentence then you've got
this this sort of structural problem and
this sort of structural problem is not
so easy to integrate everything into as
your typical off-the-shelf machine
learning toolkit right so the thing is
most of the toolkits out there still are
kind of doing glorified multiple-choice
questions right glorified regression
models or classification which just says
given this example the correct answer is
ABCD or T right yeah with highest
probability yeah but when you're talking
about language understanding language
interpretation what you're doing is
you're taking an idea that's been framed
in one way and you're you're having to
reframe it in a different way yeah so
that kind of reframing is not really a
multiple choice question writing like if
I give you a sentence in Japanese as I
say right how many possible hypotheses
are there for what the English
translation is it's not it's not gonna
be a b c d or e right the number of
possible english sentences is enormous
it's like it's infinite right it's as a
multiple choice question that doesn't
really make sense so this is why
reframing which is the basis of
interpreting language and translating
language yeah is fundamentally a much
more difficult problem but is the key to
intelligence right because that
intelligence is about being able to take
that you're perceiving and translating
it exact into a more useful
representation yeah it's a lot of what
we do on the show exactly yeah there you
go we take the brilliance from people
and then we try and make it relatable
yeah yeah
so I see how language there's thousands
of languages are there yeah roughly
8,000 8,000 languages yeah
many going extinct Rosetta project with
long now is working on yeah preserving
those languages that's so interesting
how language evolved and then how many
languages are going extinct like I think
it's like a dozen every two weeks or
something like that it's yeah yeah I
don't know what's I forgot what the
exact number was but he just that we we
need a you know a universal language
yeah that's one language no how does
that sound to you guys what do you think
living language oh you know what I I
think and and I'm gonna have to back up
a step to answer this right because
because one of the things that happens
to me a lot these days is people ask me
what's the next big thing in a Yanni and
and I I kind of stop them in and say
wait a minute okay first of all the next
big thing isn't big it's small right
because real AI doesn't work on big data
real AI is able to learn the right
generalizations the way children do from
small amounts of data that's the true
test of a I right and the next big thing
isn't a thing it's it's relating things
we have this tendency especially in the
Western philosophical tradition goes
back to Aristotle at least of trying to
reduce ideas to things
right it's comforting because these
these abstract ideas that we have
problems getting a hold on if we can
just objectify them if we turn them into
objects then it feels like oh okay
we can manipulate it we've got control
of it right and so we do this for tons
of ideas we do this for you know like
you think about ideas like temperature
it's not really a thing regret
incremental ism morality these aren't
really things right we we we use our
metaphoric ability out of language to
try to turn them into things to give us
this illusion of control but but the
thing is that's not really what
intelligence is about and it's not
really but the truth of the matter the
truth of the matter is not the object
right the truth of the matter is
actually subjective it's how you
perceive this thing and so what you're
doing is you're relating your visual
representation of this to another
representation that says oh that's a
water bottle or some other visual
language and so only because I have
actually had a couple hundred examples
of what that is in the past
exactly initially taught that label from
the first or second example and then now
I carry that label with me so you know
like what really makes the intelligence
possible is your ability to translate
from one representation into another
representation it's not the thing itself
it's the ability to translate between
one thing and another thing it's the
relationship between the representations
and you know and so this tendency to try
to objectify everything is everywhere in
in our training in order
and it permeates the scientific culture
right the scientific culture we try to
in in modeling we try to turn everything
into things right because then we can
make a theory about the things yeah
right and and so even in the study of
language in linguistics so we and where
does this want to get some real durable
even live then yeah we're so yeah where
does that even it's so so it's the
relationship ability the ability to
relate
that's the question where does that live
yeah where does that live right yeah
there's not really water bottle idea
it's you know relating it yellow tea yes
so branding it as a water bar right from
the first couple examples and then
relating to it as a water bottle over
and over again where does that live
where does that relation yeah and that's
really the key to what objective then
yeah so between the human and the object
that's where the relation exists Wow
okay we can look at it in the real world
that's way but it's really not so much
between the water bottle and up here
it's between your perception of their
water bottle and what's up here yeah um
I mean I don't want to go all
solipsistic on you but like you like
salt ism yeah but you know for all we
know there's no water bottle there we
just think there's a water bottle the
rigors of our presumption anyway so like
this goes back to modeling the mind
rather than modeling the world right so
what we're modeling is the relationship
between the percept yeah have their
water Bob Joe and the rest of what's
going on up here in that relationship
that's the key right so so just see for
the object if you yeah it's kind of so
it's not so much the other right so
here's the thing right so the science
notice by the way how signs glorifies
this notion of objectivity yes right and
it science hates subjectivity that bias
is everywhere right
but really when you're talking about
interpretation when you're talking about
translation which is the fundamental
building block of intelligence that
ability is
objective ability how you proteins model
how you pretty different from how other
people might translate the bottle right
how you translate the pattern there is
different how you translate the word cut
is subjective subjectivity is actually
the root of intelligence and so
interesting but subjectivity is like
derivative intelligence on cell we make
consensus around the subjective
perceptions then it's an objective these
all sub degree then objectivity is also
a part of the root of intelligence just
to some degree yeah yeah but I see how
subjectivity is the root then of of how
I perceive and then what that is logged
as and interpreted as and then how I
perceive again and how it's logged and
interpreted and Inter place within the
reality that I live in and the
subjective understanding of that reality
and then if we can make objective
understandings of the objects like the
water bottle then we all have this name
for the same object which makes it
easier for us to be like pass me the
water bottle can I fill your water
bottle otherwise we would have how would
we even how would I even mmm how would I
even say to communicate that phrase
right right can I feel we're assuming
that we have a consensual reality here
yeah yeah but but what would we use
besides language we couldn't we what's
net like what isn't that no we would use
language but the thing is there are many
many different languages right I mean
I'm sort of coming back to this question
that rod was asking about like is it
that we need a universal language and
and I'm gonna hypothesize knows that's
so much universal language that we need
it's the that what's the universal is
the human ability to relate different
like receive and relay different
languages many different representation
languages right see because because it
again even in scientific thinking it's
the the thinking has been colored by
this objectification tendency so Chomsky
right yeah things of language as a thing
right and and is all about what is the
grammar of that thing what is the
structure of that thing
right but language by itself as a thing
is useless a you know picture yourself
as a caveman right and somebody behind
you yells look out for the tiger behind
you if you do the Chomsky thing and you
just go mmm that was a very grammatical
sentence that was a good thing your
dinner the what what kept us alive is oh
the ability to relate that to a symbolic
representation or visual representation
that was more useful in your head
because it told you run like mad right
and so it's that relating ability that's
interesting so slow Chomsky
you know has spent a lot of his career
asking what are the universal properties
of human language and I think the right
place to be asking the question is
really what are the universal properties
of our ability to relate languages the
late ability yeah relatability between
languages and that's where the real
power comes from thinking our ability to
create you know to think it comes from
the richness of being able to take an
idea that is framed in one language and
rapidly shift it translate it into a
different representation that gives us a
new insight and then shift that into yet
another representation and so really
good creative thinking it's all about
constant translation between many
different languages that we're playing
with Wow just makes me understand even
more so why being a polymath is so
important hmm
yeah yeah because the relatability
between the different languages that are
being spoken across different interests
that people have in the complexities of
those interests as you dive even deeper
into those fields how to make them
relatable across these different
specialties and languages is so inch
cuz the one that's off 15-minute timer
thank you Ron good because it's so cool
oh you're trying to DJ it was on loop by
accident I'm never gonna get ahead in
this business he's good DJ that music
wow you have the relatability yeah I
wanna gosh I wanna I wanna maybe maybe
let's let's unpack the relatability with
the Pareto distribution at the same time
because I want to hear your thoughts
about this so as things evolve we also
notice that words like the of and which
2 etc are very highly used words like
the word the is 1 out of every 6 words
that we use and so the top 20% of words
used constitute 80% of all of oak AB you
Larry so but that's not just English
that's Chinese and Russian and
Portuguese and [ __ ] all of them
applied to the same Pareto distribution
right so how where what is what the hell
is that and then that's also visible and
like you know the amount you know 20 20
% of the floor space in this room gets
80% of the walking right so how do how
does this you know you nobody ever walks
in that corner but everybody walks right
there from the doorway to the stage here
so now like I feel sorry for that corner
of the lot I gotta go walk in that
corner of it give it some love yeah you
know like this is of course an empirical
observation about the world right and so
distribute when we use various
distributions and probabilistic models
we tend to choose distributions that
exhibit that sort of 8020 rule because
it then gives us the right priors for
how we're going to learn about that
world it also helps us obviously in the
machine learning there
I don't know maybe that's not so obvious
so so here's the thing that makes the
barreto principle or zip slaw so
important for the way kids learn
language is that if you try to learn all
of English at the same time or all of
Chinese or all Spanish or all of
whatever at the same time you're not
gonna succeed it's it's really tough
because of that kind of complexity over
here how do we actually tackle that kind
of complexity mmm we followed the slaw
we follow to learn the easy stuff first
the most common common names or nouns
first the common verbs first right
because that gives you an anchor you may
not understand each bubble or but you
can throw whoa you got it right and you
kind of know that's an important
separator and that's what comes right
before and what comes right after eat is
really important and then you start
holding on and if you remember the word
like Comair in Spanish and then
someone's talking and then all of a
sudden you would like hold he said eat
in the sentence because I I at least I
caught this something yeah right and
it's interesting it's telling how that's
the word that you but you know like this
is or career run yeah yeah
right yeah so and and in fact that kind
of behavior so so the you know like the
mathematical breakthroughs in machine
translation modeling that that we worked
on actually the way they attack that is
specifically by being able to hone in on
that kind of learning behavior and I
won't get it as a gory combinatorial
mascare but like it's if if you can have
a probabilistic or neural machine
learning model where having a word like
eat has been anchored for you and then
focus on what comes immediately before
or after that
yeah and how that yeah translates into
your more useful language then that's
where you can start to make headway
on learning that space even with that
small amount of data the Pareto
principle applying to child children
understanding language yes language
Arusha yeah okay you know we have
another friend Basel in DC that studies
language and he is so interesting and I
should talk to him more now I have I
have a question that Ron initially
brought up about about language
universal language and then you replied
by talking about love the relatability
between languages so where does the next
like era of relatability between
languages and between each other between
the objects what what is this next era
of relatability from a science point if
you are from a social point of view
maybe from them together
Tiffany the the animals already have
discovered this it's you know with their
did bird chirps and the dolphin and then
lion roar that's that's sleep that's the
language maybe they all understand each
other's little noises no I'm just being
silly here but it's possibility maybe
the whole purpose of evolution it's not
it's to go from this human thing to you
know what animal you know Jacob what
what would but is that is there
something that can be progressed to that
is a shorter more effective use of me
vibrating vocal cords and you going hi I
know what you're saying I mean you know
I think I think there's really a lot
from the scientific side we're still
pushing heavily on how to make those
models that learn the relatability even
more efficient in terms of being able to
take small amounts of data and make very
efficient generalizations correctly of
them
at a social level I think it's really
really critical again because of the
times that we we are now living in you
know when I when I finished my work at
at Berkeley my PhD work I was thinking
okay what am I going to apply this new
paradigm of probabilistic machine
learning approaches to and the reason I
chose to work on translation is
precisely because we are living in a
time where it's becoming you know at the
same time that you have these
exponential technologies it also means
that we're living in a time of
exponential risk because these
technologies can be applied for all
sorts of destructive yeah
meet aims and and Romanian Polsky on
last night talking about AI safety and
security that's great yeah oh it's gonna
say meeting us in oh yeah you were um
yeah oh that's great haha so we so so so
you know this is really a time when it's
almost like anybody can walk into a
7-eleven and buy weapons of mass
destruction it's getting so easy to
build really really exponentially cheap
and exponentially dangerous yes things
and and so to me relatability is super
important because the only chance I see
of the races survival is if we can also
exponentially increase the relatability
between people between groups so that
this ridiculous amount of destructive
power isn't just triggered and brought
in all the time yeah and that's a tall
order I mean this is something that you
which has not mastered for eons yeah we
were talking about that a lot yesterday
about war war war war war how is it just
gonna all Sun turn into peace it's gonna
it requires all seven-and-a-half billion
people to somehow figure out how to
relate to each other if that's even
possible we talked about it potentially
even being not possible for that to
happen exactly I mean yes the history of
humanity has been up until now that our
ability to out run the power of the
technologies would invent you know
coming to the new world whatever and
we've sort of reached that limit I mean
I know there are a few people that are
thinking about running into space not a
whole lot of the species is gonna be
able to do that as far as I can see in
within the timeframe that we need oh and
so I think we really need to be focusing
on on you know a problem that I call
exponential peacemaking because without
that we we're going to extinct you say
that like it's a bad thing well you know
part of me also agrees with Ron as well
like if it's you know if so so be it you
know exponential peacemaking important
to pass along but you know this human
experiment has all this there's so many
of these little rocks orbiting stars
with little populations on them that
have evolved and different very with
different variables so maybe it is maybe
the Fermi filter holds true for once the
intelligence comes that there's that
they can't figure it out
maybe we do figure it out we have to
shift unconscious and you know there's
there's people among us that enjoy
inflicting pain and people among us did
don't and it's you know that's that's
the division yeah we asked about
artificial general intelligence we asked
about bio warfare because these things
are becoming cheaper and cheaper so is
yes strapping a gun to a drone or so is
even bio warfare manufacturing anything
that can just transmit it through
even error and you just get right to
somebody else then we also asked about
wealth inequality on the show a lot like
what are we gonna do about socioeconomic
status being there being such a big gap
between the ultra rich and the poor I
think you know I think Pinker is very
smart and I talked about him a decent
amount on the show for indicating that
you know everyone and the bottom is
slowly coming up that's a fantastic
thesis to talk about and to educate
people on because I think it overall
tells people that oh it's actually going
up for everybody but the up for
everybody doesn't solve the more major
concern which is what's going on as the
people at the top are going way way up
way faster than the people on the bottom
have a much slower growth rate yeah and
so we talk we talk about these questions
a lot on the show and it's good to hear
some of some of your perspective about
it I absolutely I mean pretty much
everything that I am working on is
targeted at that problem right now
you know exponential peacemaking is a
great concept but to actually take it
from the abstract into concrete reality
it means tackling problems like that how
do you tackle problems like that these
are cultural problems these are mindset
problems which means these are problems
that are framed by the language that the
problems are the the situations are
discussed in terms of we really need to
think about how we are framing these
problems and a lot of the work that I'm
working on now which is you know this is
all stuff that isn't even out there yet
it's the neck the next paradigm shift is
how do we shift the work that we've been
pioneering over the last several decades
on getting machines to reframe things
from one human you know from Chinese in
English or from Spanish into Arabic or
whatever how do we now
shift that toward helping us to reframe
ideas in more healthy ways that help us
to focus on the key problems that we
need to tackle how do we help people to
reframe their perception of maybe some a
problem that will have been previously
dismissed and is slowly getting out of
control and it's going to generate
exactly the kind of tensions that we
just talked about needing to avoid and
help people to understand what why is
that problem actually serious and and
why why is it problem I care about we
just had a conversation about this also
a couple nights ago after the Michael
Pollan event we chatted about the
importance of slipping in the importance
of these conversations into society in a
way where people don't even know that it
got slipped in there and that now all of
a sudden they're talking about it so
just like you we don't really know that
the words of which to and that we don't
really know that those words became
slipped into our language we don't
really study that that much most people
don't
similarly too if all of a sudden
exponential peacemaking and artificial
general intelligence and these these
these concepts these abstract thoughts
become more embedded into our the 20% of
words that we use most often
which then constitute 80% of all
conversation then all of a sudden we
might actually be on to something yeah
absolutely that's interesting I wouldn't
know and you know like more than 90% of
what we do we're not aware of you know
it's what in in psychology you know the
distinction is between automatic
processing and and conscious processing
and and you know 90% of what we do is is
below the level of conscious awareness
yeah but that is where the meat is that
that is where we need to relate to each
other so I think the autonomic and
autonomic nervous system blinking and
the breathing and yeah well above that
level even above that like I mean above
the brains
but like sort of you know things like
going back to the cut example Oh food if
I say you know how do you cut disc space
you don't have to think about which
sense of cut is that is right or a level
of your conscious awareness um yeah
unprocessed I love that it's the
automatic inference conscious might be
like making a decision then about
something that you actually need to
consciously contemplate for a little bit
right right that you have to reflect
it's a reflective reasoning reflective
introspective reasoning right we we
don't do that very much you're right
almost so much of the reality is
automatic yeah I mean every word of
every sentence that you say is pretty
much many way ambiguous in the same way
as the word cut was yeah yeah exactly
yet none of us are thinking consciously
about any of that
yeah yeah so much of what goes on it's
totally automatically part of social
fabric in the way that we interact and
the way that we abide to the political
and economic fabric of the world where
are we at quick where are we at with the
dialog agents there's still kind of nice
toys right now I mean they're getting
useful I mean the series the Alexus you
know yeah assistants I've seen them get
into emotions now where you can talk to
an actual yeah human on the to Deesa
plane and they'll like have their you
know they will never get angry at you
they'll always be kind and I just to
find this really interesting
yeah yeah I mean this is all it's good
to model it's not too hard actually
surprisingly the hard stuffs still not
being tackled the way these dialog
agents that are out in the commercial
world right now work they're still very
nice hacks
they make mistakes no three-year-old
would make gosh do I have time to show
you another example why don't you show
us did you have the other one lined up
that you wanted a show yeah I can do
that
let's get just give me a second line it
I will keep we'll keep it we'll keep it
quick but I want you to be able to show
what you've been working on this one
yeah so if you if you think about what a
three-year-old kid does right the kind
of language that three-year-olds use
there's a typical example right where
does it go mm-hmm and three-year-olds
have no problem with this kind of thing
and so like the problem is that if you
think about how other languages express
the same idea right so this is Chinese
and Chinese you might say kai found out
her there's the common word where mmm
but nothing else is coming right what
this sort of says is should put where
should put where uh-huh and that's in
common and yet yeah they mean the same
thing kids have no problems with it from
from either language yeah and before you
say oh that's just Chinese and English
are so different here's Swedish Swedish
is one of the closest languages to
English
farts got it and yet same problem only
the word where is in common trait in
sweeter sources where should that were
sure that in fact the the Swedish shares
more income with the Chinese Wow and so
you know like this is this is the kind
of problem that we're still facing right
when you asked about dialogue agents why
do they make mistakes that no
three-year-old would make it's because
the kind of AI that those nice very nice
hacks is built out of yeah doesn't even
try to tackle this problem of the fact
that the meaning is as much in what's
not said yeah as in what is that right
we've done this for dozens of languages
and and kids have absolutely no problem
with whichever language but you feed it
to a machine to translate and it gets
them all wrong right that's how weak our
AI today still is
and this is why I think it's worth the
fascination of really focusing on these
questions of strong AI like how do we
tackle the real AI problems we're living
in a time when obviously a met there's
massive AI hype all over the place right
and everybody's grabbing toolkits off
the shelf feeding it big pieces of data
turning the crank and oh look magic
there's a lot of low-hanging fruit there
there's a lot of good ways to make money
there like you said the small changes
are gonna be the ones that make some
more big change but yeah it's it's 80/20
rule again right yeah shifting the work
to be able to handle these kinds of
issues is gonna have you massive effect
yeah yeah this is relatability this is
language this is what we talked about
today
cognitive science evolution the
development of the human mind from
childhood and the way that we have built
civilization using language and
relatability you yeah you you were very
interesting that guy I really enjoyed
having you on the show
oh my such a pleasure to be on the show
thank you for having me honey I'm trying
to figure out why I got offended when he
said how weak artificial intelligence is
it makes me question Who am I why did I
get offended when you said that it's
crazy talk about thoughts going way but
how did that how did that feeling of
being offended actually feel nobody you
know this is just how weak our
intelligence isn't something it was like
an attack on me I don't get it you've
absorbed so much San Francisco hype now
Ron I am NOT real this is a machine the
kite we get let's can we go through a
quick final questions with you that we
ask on the show sure what's the most
beautiful thing in the world oh my god I
should have done my my homework
Wow that's a that's a challenging one
Wow such a simple question such a such
an amazing question that you know the
images that run through my mind and
feelings everyone through my mind you
know I get everything flashes through my
head from the these incredible mountains
in the Karakoram range jagged gigantic
you know it's the range where k2 is by
Mount Everest or k2 so so Everest is in
the Himalayas yep
so the Himalayas are an older mountain
range and so they're all rounded the
Karakoram czar basically the same height
you know k2 differs from the height of
Everest only by a tiny insignificant
amount but they're a young range they're
younger in so they're like super jagged
and I remember sitting in this little
village in Pakistan before everything
went crazy and Pakistan long before that
and and you know sitting like my chai
and admiring this huge mountain jagged
beautiful and they're like rivers and
ice and everything and just admiring it
and then the clouds lifted and I
realized that was a foot hill and the
mountain was there oh yeah I mean that
that's just one of the images that ya
ran that ran through that's a good one
yeah I like the visual that you painted
for that look at this place is freakin
incredible
I mean k2 is like right there right like
it yeah yeah exactly
that is right there we miss very good
like like there's so much beauty on this
planet and then there's the beauty and
how we've evolved and communicates so
difficult to actually pick things do you
think we're alone in the cosmos
as a good scientist I'm gonna say I
don't know I kind of doubt it chances
are not high of that if you look at it
scientifically do you think advanced
civilizations are roaming the cosmos hmm
as a good scientist I was chances are
not bad yeah yeah why are they avoiding
us is that what you're saying there's a
bunch of zoo hypothesis there's so many
of those do you think that we're in a
computer simulation your standard
questions we have more we have a list of
like a hundred of these yeah we sort of
already went under solecism yeah no and
how could you know if you pay attention
it's a suggestion that it it is it's not
it's a game it's not a simulation we do
have free will and these are machines
and it's just a game and it's
fascinating but you have to focus on
that you know if you're busy doing other
things you know if all you were to do is
focus on that question hmm
you would the answer would be
unfortunately yes
yeah yeah yeah I'm not a good sign are
you hoping for like you know I don't
know like little matrix like glitches
somewhere that are getting like Blade
Runner I haven't seen the new one but
don't think it's suggest was another old
movie you know same tricks the actual
yeah right no the more you look the more
you find as well it's the same thing
when you look at a tree the more you
look the more you realize oh there's a
squirrel running oh look at the way the
Sun lights hitting the leaves you know
the longer you look the more you find
that's true
let let me turn the question around
though sure is is there a difference
yeah we've had that counter question
asked and the most important answer to
that question that I've found so far is
that the study of simulation theory
itself is so consciousness expanding and
awareness extent enhancing that that in
itself is why we talk about it because
it gives us such a good understanding of
things or better understanding of the
actual world that we live in and all the
variables that are being calculated in
order to produce the reality that we
live in but the crunching of those
variables is different across different
rocks orbiting stars and different time
periods of evolution but the answer to
the question about it there being a
difference we don't we don't quite know
what if they if you knew this was
reality versus if you knew this was a
simulation how would it change your
behavior today we're not quite sure I
see this as oh okay here here's a
different way we're talking about the
ambiguity of language of what difference
means right so like is there a is there
a difference between reality and a
simulation okay I'm following me so
here's the thing right we were doing
when we asked that question we're doing
objectification again you're you've
objectified this notion of reality yeah
but so you so so we reality is a thing
now we can hold it now we can manipulate
it we're more comfortable with it but
reality isn't really a thing it's a
metaphor it's a mob reality in a
simulation what is the difference
between them so if I really if I really
go back to what I was touching on board
one's not with with the emphasis on some
subjectiveness on what's what we really
focus on is this ability to relate to
shift between different yes
then what reality is is relevant like
whether there is even such a thing as
reality because that's the odd that's
the object right so you're talking about
how do I my mind really how does my mind
relate to reality
I've already objectified this thing
called reality which is a which is a
metaphor this is something that I'm
modeling my personal case well then we
can assume we can bring it to the
subjective interpretation of existence
and then whether or not it's a reality
or simulation is secondary to just the
way that you subjectively interpret
what's going on it's really my
interpretation process that's the thing
that's really happening yeah but your
interpretation Buddhist about this but I
like it though but and your music has
Buddhists of in tendencies within it do
you do you that the product of the way
that you're perceiving things though the
perception of it and the understanding
of it that's going on that that itself
might not actually be you doing that
sure okay so then I guess that's the
difference between the reality and the
simulation is it actually you doing the
relating or is it so do you like
recursion
I know 0.001 percent I'm not recursion
well but well I mean here very very
simply when you say is it you doing it
what is you we've we've just objectified
again yeah you're right yeah we did okay
so I really kind of going you know is it
Turtles all the way down this is this is
interesting though I think we need to
unpack this at least another just a
little bit because this is the probably
some of the more interesting simulation
conversation we've had but we do we do
should definitely bring the show to an
end but I do I'm liking where this is
going this is interesting I really
appreciate you bringing this up who is
the you what is the you what is the I
without time what is so Duke I thank you
so much for coming on to the show
thank you very much real real pleasure I
had such a good time and we learned so
much about about language and music and
relatability development of the species
how he actually got to where we are
today what you showed us was you know
actually bringing in those examples of
visually is really interesting as well
and actually we'll put the link for
reorient reorient tape on the bio as
well okay so we can get some of your
music listen to great get some more
music listen to check out just all about
relatability decays music yes and
cognitive ambiguities and illusions it's
interesting let's definitely give it a
listen put the link in the bio everyone
thank you so much for tuning in if you
guys had a good time you've the content
to share with other people definitely
give us a comment below subscribe let us
know your thoughts
we'd love to hear from you and if you
think that you're done by just watching
this you're not you got to go create
with this now so go write about it go
make a video about it go and start
something yourself in helping people
better understand relatability and join
us on patreon help us support the studio
help us keep growing this endeavor we'd
love to have your support and thanks to
our producing partner Ron Vargas Alfredo
as well
our team thank you guys for watching
we'll see you soon
you